[Musique]
nous voici de retour dans le pays qui a
fait de nous des parents nous avons
adopté nos deux enfants au vietnam notre
aventure débute ici dans la capitale sur
le pont du soleil levant c'est là que
nous avons rendez vous avec tous chine
notre ami qui nous a accompagnés dans
nos démarches d'adoption par les valeurs
caunes est sûre je vois bien le
reconnaître c'est déjà venu tu avais un
mois c'est pour ça tu t'en souviens
c'est parce que tu l'as vu en photo je
me souviens même tu vois qu'on s'est
assis sur ce banc là et on t'avait
donner un biberon
[Musique]
alors est ce que tu vois tout chine
super de voir si
un jour tu vois bien un jour tu chine va
regarder comme on les connaît c'est un
super
coq au
second perd connaissance et légumes
on s'est connus ce qui est dommage c'est
comme il ya deux ans oui
ils sont très bons alexandre
certainement depuis le petit bébé
maintenant un garçon
petit garçon mignon comme tout j'aime
bien organisé à hanoi
on est parti je pleurais parce que je
dis bon viendra un jour la no2 plonge
vraiment on se croirait en 2010 avec
notre petit notre petit alex ou tout
bébé en train de faire connaissance l'un
et l'autre voilà la famille réunie et
puis tout chine avec nous pour partager
ce moment c'est super super
[Musique]
c'est notre troisième voyage au vietnam
la première fois nous sommes venus
adopté canine la seconde c'était pour
alexandre cette fois ci nous venons pour
que nos enfants renouent avec leurs
racines un retour aux sources qui
démarre dans l'agitation d'hanoï avec
ses millions de scooters la ville rue j
24 heures sur 24
à voir les yeux grands écarquillés de
camille d'alexandre on mesure le
dépaysement nous nous venons de la
campagne en lorraine alors forcément
pour eux c'est vraiment différent alors
doublons ou quelque chose à boire
il est très fatigué
mais il est tellement intéressé ti
[Musique]
à la lumière de tout ça
am
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre rêve une fois
traversé le fleuve rouge nous savons que
nous cheminons vers le passé de nos
enfants vers la terre qui les a vus
naître
plus partout en train vers le sud cap
sur la région de nam dinh là où notre
fille aînée
[Musique]
combien de fois j'ai rêvé de filer droit
vers le grand ouest vivre le rêve
américain sauf que cette fois ci c'est
pour de vrai me voici au volant au sud
de l'arizona je vais accomplir ce qui me
tient à coeur depuis que je suis gamine
vite qu'au bord et je parlais une
semaine dans nos rangs du tennis et des
mots rooney
[Musique]
sandrine oui c'est bien moi content de
te rencontrer un chanteur de tango
bonjour débit je suis heureuse que tu
n'en ai trouvé
bienvenu.merci
oit voici l'autre chez nous c'est un
ranch plan did we nous l'avons construit
suis venu ici pour nous aider on
a tellement à faire que de l'aide est
toujours là bien
on a plain d'occupation courtois
n'a pas peur de te salir les mains en
moi oui aucun souci pour moi bon alors
c'est parti
pour mon baptême chez les cowboys
l'épreuve imposée celle là ce métier
indispensable pour attraper le bétail et
c'est pas gagné pour m'initier j'ai un
coach de choix gordon pour le fils de
dennis alors je te donne un petit secret
quand tu prends ton la swing fait des
coups comme ça les gardes du lest avec
tes doigts
tu verras c'est plus facile
amtrak qui d'entre elles c'est pour de
vrai mais c'est pas faire parce que là
les vaches et bouge pas et déjà serait
de se sauver
n'importe quand elles vont bouger
non mais je dis vrai cowboy
pour m'aider
à y aller encore une fois
ça me rapproche
[Applaudissements]
première épreuve réussie maintenant
façon au choix du cheval de cow boy doit
être en parfaite osmose avec sa monture
bah ça y est là c'est mon favori les
chevaux
voilà ok
c'est une jument très sympa
je propose que vous fassiez connaissance
car ça va être ton cheval
à toute la famille phare à cheval pour
regrouper le bétail le cowboy est
d'abord et avant tout un gardien de
vaches
alors accessoires fondamental pour
monter à cheval une paire de bottes
et un chapeau pour
le soleil la poussière et les bottes ça
protège les mots les
os peuvent c'est parfait et de goût
aussi sarah que c'est bon de faire
éclater ses pairs
me voici donc dans ce qui ressemble à un
western dennis avec sa barbe zz top et
moi en calamity jane
la liberté il n'y a rien à perdre de vue
que les montagnes on s'en va direct sur
mexico y'a pas de mots pour décrire ce
paysage cf landed
chevauchée ne fait que commencer le
territoire de dénis s'étend sur plus de
dix mille hectares il n'y a rien de
comparable en france il va donc falloir
plusieurs heures pour voir apparaître
les premières vaches
[Musique]
moi c'est théo depuis que je marche je
n'ai qu'une obsession être toujours un
peu plus près des étoiles c'est au chili
on se rapproche le plus
on arrivait
et maintenant
freestyle
[Musique]
coup de bol pour moi le chili est aussi
le meilleur terrain de surf sur le sable
et moi avec les étoiles la glisse mon
kiff
oh
[Musique]
j'en plante ça fait sur mars c'est trop
coulant
mais n'allez pas croire que je suis un
ado juste intéressés par le support
je passe cette année mon bac
scientifique
mon rêve devenir astronome c'est dans le
nord du pays sur les plateaux perchet de
l'altiplano que nous attend demain des
astronomes du plus grand site
d'observation des étoiles la base de
l'allemand
[Musique]
bonjour enchanté
bienvenue sur le site albin et notre
petite forêt d'antennes en construction
ici tout autour de nous j'ai entendu
dire que tu voulais devenir astronome
depuis c'est aussi ça depuis tout petit
je regardais et ben écoute je pense que
tu es au bon endroit et tu voir qui
c'est un grand succès beaucoup de choses
qui s'y passe denis sera mon coach c'est
l'un des meilleurs astronomes français
il est diplômé de l'une des plus
prestigieuses universités américaines
il a passé un en antarctique alors moi
du haut de mes 6 piges j'ai un peu le
vertige en l'écoutant sénateurs qui dort
jamais parce qu'il ya des activités 24
heures sur 24
très correct de dire
oui pour les 10 15 prochaines années en
termes de capacités de découverte
scientifique comme par exemple comme par
exemple la compréhension des endroits où
est cachée où se forment les étoiles la
formation des étoiles la formation des
systèmes solaires autour des toiles
ce n'est pas un hasard si des
scientifiques du monde entier ont choisi
celui-ci le ciel est ici le plus sec et
le plus pur au monde nous sommes dans le
désert d'atacama nous observent les
phénomènes puisse d'incroyables visible
à même le sol tout autour de la base je
tombe nez un endroit
surprenant qui s'appelle le créateur de
montaut la quille
en voyant ce décor sur la route je ne
crois déjà sur nos plaintes le cratère
de mentorat qu'il est rare impacts de
météorites encore visible sur terre il
est connu que par quelques initiés
peut-on dire que son gps c'est mort
tu as confiance à la technologie ouais
j'ai confiance moi pas trop j'ai
toujours surpris quand ça marche mais
bon on essaie un des mois les secours
très bizarre d'aller à l'aveuglent
c'est gentil à des gens qui ont
fabriqué des carmes pour nous
donc on voyait sur
bientôt arriver france
avec exactitude 100 m de nulle part
attends attends
à temps
[Musique]
vous lis ça vous chante
c'est rare quand même à sortir les
impacts de cratères
[Musique]
ce n'est pas l'atmosphère terrestre à
terre serait comme ça tous les 300 km
-sur et un tri un cratère
c'est vraiment et sinon je pense qu'un
jour si tu marches sur la lune ne doit
pas être très différente ça
pour moi c'est une grande première vue
que c'est la première fois que le
curseur pour de vrai un créateur
météorites et tu rentres et que je
rentre dans un cratère tu veux écouter
le cratère asie
voilà ça part dans tous les sens
la dernière étape avant la grande
descente
dutourd de chiny
choisi avance avance avance avance
non
[Musique]
nous poursuivons l'exploration du site
qui entourent la base scientifique du
nid me fait découvrir ce que l'on
surnomme ici la vallée de la lune je
comprend vite pourquoi
le sel qui donne cette couleur lunaire
c'est bon
c'est impressionnant ce que tu observes
dans le ciel mais
ça tellement peu de relations humaines
que la voilà là on se sent fait partie
de la montagne avec le font un peu
partie assez sauvage ont fait partie des
éléments exactement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fois la nuit tombée je réalise
pourquoi de nîmes emmener jusqu ici la
voûte céleste s'offre à nous on a
presque l'impression de toucher les
étoiles un sentiment que je n'ai encore
jamais eu on la voit bien c'est que ces
maps entre fête battait pas le seul
[Musique]
ça y est on largue les amarres nous
tenions à faire cette escale avec nos
enfants revenir dans la baie d'halong un
lieu chargé de souvenirs on va t'on sur
le rocher
[Musique]
aller à camille vaz et amis
c'est bien pour les enfants le connaître
quand même leur pays natal et
je trouve que ce que vous avez fait
christophe pour les enfants c'est très
important ça vaut tout l'or du monde
tiens regarde tous chine et je suis en
train de chercher tout à l'heure je suis
tombé sur une photo d'alex il ya deux
ans une photo qu'on avait pris au
vietnam
[Musique]
avec touches il a quand je regarde
ces photos je me rends compte que
finalement
deux ans c'est court mais en deux ans il
ya eu un sacré chemin de parcouru ouais
ouais
[Musique]
epli
abaca les gros celui là
[Musique]
c'est le même on dirait même couleur e
la dernière fois que nous sommes venus
dans la baie d'halong nous venions tout
juste de récupérer alexandre c'était nos
tout premiers instants de détente
ensemble enfin réunis nous avions fait
escale ici dans ce village de pêcheurs
avec ses maisons sur pilotis camille
partagé alors ses premiers moments avec
son petit frère et nous nous étions si
fiers de prendre par la main nos deux
jeunes enfants deux ans plus tard nous
retrouvons la famille chez qui nous
avons pris le thé
[Musique]
et
le monsieur là ça mon âne en son nom
[Musique]
nous redécouvrons des visages familiers
des enfants qui ont bien grandi et notre
aussi d'ailleurs
voilà son frère c'est mon frère
[Musique]
ouais
ce timing
kabylie bravo
attention cette
[Musique]
je raconte dans ce cahier
toutes les émotions
plein de petites anecdotes
dont je suis sûr de ne pas me souvenir
dans quelques années c'est tout à fait
un témoignage qu'on laisse aux enfants
et puis on s'est rendu compte après deux
voyages successifs qu'on perde évite les
détails et qu'on gardait que les
émotions
je vais aussi leur laisser les détails
et parmi ces détails il y à tous ces
sourires qui nous accueille à chacune de
nos étapes aujourd'hui la baie d'halong
demain la région où est né et camille
[Musique]
enfin arrivé après plus de trois heures
à cheval nous retrouvons le premier
troppo dennis pour gordon ça ne se voit
pas encore mais les choses sérieuses ont
commencé et mon cheval au qui lui n'est
pas mécontent d'arriver à bon port
techniquement c'est du rire c'est clair
gordon et son père doivent attraper les
nouveau nés pour les marquer et ça c'est
d'objets de torture qui m'attend
ok
m
[Rires]
et
âmes sensibles s'abstenir ce n'est pas
pour le plaisir c'est ici une obligation
ticket
c'est un peu barbare maintenant c'est
leur loi
ils doivent le faire mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas la partie la plus sympa que du
bon
[Musique]
c'est comme ça ils doivent le faire mais
il veut pas être
illégaux dans leur marquage de leurs
bennes qui font tout ce qu'il ya à faire
le marquage et l'oreille coupée
permettent d'identifier chaque bête est
d'éviter le mélange de troupeaux avec le
rendre le voisin
nous devons ensuite ramené les bêtes
vers le ranch et là j'ai l'honneur
d'être aux commandes
au
boulot
quand je suis un complice
[Musique]
mais la journée est loin d'être terminée
je mesure à quel point dennis est
totalement dévoué à son ranch est assez
bête
[Musique]
après j'ai une question pour vous
wade et pourquoi avez vous décidé
d'avoir un ranch
toute ma vie j'ai voulu vivre au grand
air et me sentir libre
j'ai eu le choix entre deux modèles
j'ai vu mon père travailler dur comme
avocat être dévoré par son travail
enfermé dans son bureau
et à linverse mon grand père lui était
heureux de cultiver ses terres alors
j'ai fais comme lui je suis devenu
éleveur et j'ai un range
pour mon premier jour de repos je pars
explorer ce grand ouest qui me fascine
tant
et au petit jeu de l'auto-stop je tire
le numéro gagnant
et comment ça va et bien la bombe à bord
dont le porte et on y va mieux on est tu
t'appelles comment sandrine et toi moi
ces belles contentant entre est gentil
nous habitons recouper merci d'être
arrêté
[Musique]
avec ben nous nous retrouvons comme dans
un road movie cap vers le nord de
l'arizona avec ce drôle d'américains
plutôt sympa mon chauffeur
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi le lycée combien de
degrés une phase sensible grey paris
nights c'est une chaleur de malades ça
fait 40 degrés chez vous ça même 42 non
c'est super chaud
récente dynam surtout il ya tant
d'autres une minute je vérifier non
c'est énorme
moi été fait pourquoi est ce que c'est
si dur de le prendre parce que plus est
le meilleur c'est ok
tu sais ce qu'il faut dire c'est bon
c'est bon je peux vivre ici
et voilà les roches rouges baby boom
c'est de là que partent les vols en
montgolfière
croyez moi cette information tombe pas
dans l'oreille d'une sourde et c'est
avec ben ce drôle de zigoto que je
m'apprête à faire mon baptême de l'air
aux portes même du grand canyon
[Musique]
c'est super
hier
il
oyo
[Musique]
ça donne envie de vivre ici j'aimerais
bien vous pouvez emmener toute la
famille
dire au revoir à tes amis tu vois pas
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
ce tour
à
[Musique]
comme ce matin
après plusieurs jours passés dans le
désert je viens enfin me posais sur la
côte pacifique palpe à résoudre et le
port mythique du chili excès funiculaire
et ses poètes d'en bas d'un extrême à
l'autre voilà on parle d'un désert sec
farid à 3000 m d'altitude l on retourne
à l'altitude 0 avec un air vachement
humide
c'est au son de sa gratte que je fais
connaissance avec luis un jeune étudiant
qui a comme moi la tête dans les étoiles
gallas et merci à cîteaux ici si tu veux
à la connais la base alma c'est le plus
grand observatoire astronomique
tu aimes l'astronomie
ouais c'est ma passion c'est ma passion
je crois qu'on est le plus beau ciel du
monde ici et comment le chili c'est le
pays de la stran d'amiens
[Musique]
m
avec le pacifique qui m'appelle j'ai
comme une envie subite de prendre la
vague
voilà
d'accord
je suis excité là
là je suis dans mon domaine là
[Musique]
me haïk six ados
c'est plus pour pouvoir dire voilà
j'espère seront pacifiées quoi je refais
un pacifique et dans l'atlantique
saffar
comme verizon nice
[Musique]
voilà très bonnes sessions dans le
pacifique
comment très bonne la première d'année
un et
ça fait du bien de se décrasser un petit
peu avant à la main avant de monter à 5
mm ça a trop de choses on passe du
niveau zéro de leurs nerfs à 5000 mètres
d'altitude
ça va ça va être chaud patate
[Musique]
là et dans cette province
vous avez connu
qui est née dès qu'ils terminent dans
cette province est là pour rester clean
et qu'il allait devoir attendre quoi
ce n'est toi on n'a jamais eu l'occasion
de retourner grâce à tous chine nous
retrouvons l'endroit où nous avons signé
les documents pour adopter notre petit
canning c'était il ya cinquante la
petite courette intérieur donc c'est là
qu'on a pris des photos en fait on a
pris les photos de camille tout bébé
après la signature de la remise
officielle on quand tu deviens papa ou
maman a c'est comme une naissance
c'est des grands moments de bonheur je
revois camille dans mes bras à quatre
mois c'est super d'avoir pu
revenir aujourd'hui
c'est tellement
magique
[Musique]
où
on repart temps avec un petit bout de
papier mais un petit bout de papier
précieux sur lequel figure le lieu où
est née notre fille
voilà
le quart a ajouté un cahier de souvenirs
[Musique]
sauf à nous nous dirigeons au
dispensaire où est né camille où elle
est restée quelques jours avant d'être
déposé à l'orphelinat
c'est un endroit où en général on ne va
pas
donc c'est un moment rare
nous rentrons dans ceux que l'on
surnomme la baie d'halong terrestre
la grande aventure
carly
[Musique]
simon la très jolie c'est un bâtiment
important oui parce que c'est le
dispensaire où tu es né à bondy c'est ou
comme une maternité voilà
[Musique]
chaque panneau rapproche un peu plus du
passé de notre fille et il est temps
bientôt les ruines du dispensaire seront
place à une usine de chaussures signe
des temps d'un pays en pleine mutation
aussi
dans sa bouche moi c'est ça la et c'est
ça en fait dit on
non on peut pas
voilà c'est ici limite c'était pas comme
ça au début
c'est un petit bout d'histoire en plus
pour camille plus tard parce que là
c'est vrai qu'elle réalise pas trop quoi
mais nous on réalise c'est déjà ça pour
elle
nous voyons défiler devant nous un
tableau avec ses scènes de vie ses
couleurs ses personnages c'est le petit
monde de camille qui prend vie sous nos
yeux
[Musique]
c'est un boni les camions mais je me
servais
je
[Musique]
on est au contact
de la terre de camilla ouais
bah parce que on est on est très très
loin de chez nous là
ça regarde les enfants ils nous font ils
nous font coucou derrière camille y
avoir leur donner des bonbons tiens
vas-y voilà chacun sait pas si bas de la
grande grande âme gandhi
c'est petit enfants sont nés à nam dinh
au même endroit que pour la cami
au même endroit
bye
viendra
c'est une histoire en plus inscrire sur
son cahier souvenir m et on l'a vécu
pour de vrai
on y était on pourra lui dire own you
tell vous les salles de pieds nus pieds
nus en plus fait sentir les vibrations
j'en ai bien un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous ses airs sérieux de cowboy gordon
est encore un gamin et c'est le gamin 17
ans qui aujourd'hui prend le dessus sur
le fermi
il
sandrine je t'emmène assister un
règlement de comptes à tombstone ouais
ça va être cool ouais c'est la wii à
thorpe a vécu et est mort tu vas voir on
s'embarque dans une sacrée aventure sur
la route dr alwan ça m'a fait
rencontrer doc holliday water
[Musique]
houston est l'une des dernières villes
fantômes aux états unis à vivre à
l'heure des westerns et de la conquête
de l'ouest des habitants se sont
mobilisés pour devenir eux-mêmes des
acteurs de cette heure de gloire
[Musique]
jeudi de revenir
ouais sûr
aller haut niveau
mais je suis loin d'imaginer devenir
l'actrice principale de cette
reconstitution
cette demande et disait vrai gamine
et
puis c'est mon époque préféré en même
temps quoi
encore je vais rentrer je vais leur dire
que j'ai joué à l'époque de grandes
robes et tout
[Applaudissements]
ça rafraîchit
les hommages madame comment on va tout
va mal et vous
sans doute le clou dans quelques minutes
désolé chéri
[Musique]
j'espère cependant les matins en choeur
un flou et
en os
x
[Musique]
on
retour sur la base à demain j'arrive à
un moment clé cette antenne gigantesque
va rejoindre les autres déjà en place
pour former le plus grand télescope au
monde
garçon devient réalité pour monter dans
le camion le plus gros du monde 28 roues
ok embarquement immédiat pour une
ascension à plus de 5000 mètres
d'altitude
salut
[Musique]
presque égale
croître encore quatre heures avant
d'arriver aussi magique
tous savaient ce ponton et benzina casta
paris
[Musique]
hilton et essence 1200 litres d'essence
tu es un télescope de 200 tonnes
c'est qu'il faut
des paris mais un
il
[Musique]
je découvre enfin ce champ d'antennes
plus haut que le mont blanc
grande première pour moi
la sias
ça c'est le bâtiment technique et c'est
ici qu'ont à l'infrastructure contrôler
toutes les antennes les deuxièmes plus
haut bâtiment en bande le premier c'est
une station de tram vivait à 5100 mètres
mais avec ce niveau technologie ces
villes
[Musique]
l'inconvénient c'est que d'ici là la
pression elle est la moitié de ce qui
peut être la pression au niveau de la
mer il faut bien penser à respirer pour
clément et pour t'aider on va donner
dans la loue donner de l'oxygène y
lit-on on le dit l'impression de planer
le coupé à toit
folie j'ai réalisé que je suis sûr
le plus grand projet du monde
astronomiques
où
et
[Musique]
je dis pas par exemple
un jour c'est peut-être moi qui veut
découvrir une planète habitable un truc
comme ça j'exploite du travail sur la
toujours tu as cette question
fondamentale que tu poses à l'intérieur
d'où nous venons nous ces questions nos
origines et est toujours que cette
question qui te guide s'était dirigé un
petit peu quand tu fais des recherches
mais évidemment c'est une question qui
est vraiment aux propos très haut
profond de toi et qui n'apparaît pas
très souvent dans ses recherches dont on
travaille au jour le jour moi ça me fait
plaisir de juste d'avoir participé à la
construction d'un projet comme ça je me
dis bon ben voila j'ai mis ma pierre
dans tous les toutes les prochaines
observations qui seront faites avec alma
je sais que j'aurais participé un petit
peu à chacune des observations
je suis en train de ramasser du sable
du désert d'atacama quand on est dans
cet univers là on a vraiment
l'impression d'être sur la lune dans
l'espace factures via les télescopes on
a l'impression de déjà de planer et de
plus sur la terre
devrait suffire ça c'est bon c'est bon
là les
le moment est venu de fixer la nouvelle
antenne sur le site
la tension est à son comble la moindre
erreur peut être fatale
je suis vachement stressé pour lui parce
que je me dis c'est quand même même si
c'est la sainte la 30e qu'il installe
il ya beaucoup de choses qui peuvent qui
peuvent se passer
ces critiques comme au mans c'est un
moment critique
jusqu'aux derniers mètres ce dernier est
minime et la traction
[Musique]
soleil un conte à apa les vaisseaux sur
le reste de notre ouverture leur ligne
alma est un projet pharaonique se
télescopent le plus grand et le plus
haut du monde nous permettra peut-être
un jour de rentrer en contact avec une
vie extraterrestre
et j'aimerais être ici ce jour là mais
cette fois ci aux commandes comme
astronomes
[Musique]
dernière étape de notre voyage nous
arrivons dans la région montagneuse de
cao bang nord du vietnam une région où
vivent les minorités ethniques dont
celle de notre petit alexandre l'ethnie
taille
mais sur ce marché où cohabitent une
cinquantaine de groupes ethniques
difficile de reconnaître en tant
qu'ami est fade et gone où il abat là
[Musique]
des crevettes
cela va être
drôle et maladroit là aussi c'est la
première fois à cannes trois couples
avec des enfants comme ça a
dit c'est bien on sait bien qu'ils ont
adoptée c'est bien
elle est très proche avenir
cela dit que c'est une chance pour qu'il
a de vivre au fond
chine arrive à identifier une femme qui
pourrait être de l'ethnie d'alexandre
à balma de la
ressemblance
anime une île au sort à
7 premier vrai contact avec eux avec la
tribu taille en ethnies taille pour
laisser
jamais eu l'occasion de rencontrer avant
c'est la première fois
on pourra lui dire quand il y était
on
une fois le marché terminé cette femme
nous propose la suivre pour nous
présenter sa famille tous détails
[Musique]
les cendres
familles
du village de
taper chez toi ici mon soutien à ces
sont des gens de la même ethnie que
trois tailles comme toi hein est ce
c'est une mamie le paraguay
bélize alors sa maison ses fans se
sentent bien une mise en plis sa taille
ce plan
[Musique]
les mid alexandre théa y on en a
vraiment trouvé très peu de choses ont
donc là c'est
vraiment un grand moment
alors là j'ai l'impression
là j'ai l'impression d'avoir 70 ans
et demi en suisse à côté de moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et même s'il te plaît
[Musique]
à
ces différentes chez nous occupions
différent des visages je pense que ce
sera imprimé dans leur mémoire et
continuent quand on s'en souvenir et ça
ça remontera la surface est plus
touchant je pensais les enfants à chaque
fois commencé la rencontre avec les
enfants
c'est pas les mêmes conditions que chez
nous et pourtant ils sont ils ont
toujours le sourire
[Musique]
vous
ni
moi qui me manque
[Musique]
retour à hanoi pour finir notre séjour
nous tenons à honorer une tradition bien
locale le portrait de famille façon
vietnamienne
[Musique]
m
à riom
[Musique]
son maquis
mcqueen
tiens pas comme un militaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
tu fais ça
[Musique]
non
à
c'est un
comme ce match
et
ça a été formidable
merci pour ton aide merci pour votre
accueil je suis tellement content de
vous avoir rencontré
il faut absolument que tu reviennes avec
ta famille
au très grand on se voit bientôt
peut-être en france
[Musique]
cathy z'en pensez pas que je viens de
travail ici au chili en attendant ça
c'est vraiment moi répond du travail la
persévérance et d'avoir confiance en soi
à long terme
les passions ça vous rend fort se disent
nos projets d'astronomes a c'est
vraiment super le fait de
d'être dans une basse ainsi comme ça
avec que des scientifiques et être en
permanence à temps c'était décevant
génial et moi je crois que c'est ce que
je veux faire plus tard quoi vraiment
mais vraiment on se retrouve dans 15 ans
puis on verra ça semblait tient au
château
[Musique]
les enfants vont dire au revoir à
cushing haut
ce dont tu
[Musique]
m'as repêchée
oui merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
où
c'est ma bulle et je suis encore
alors comme ça
intenable un pays un peu spéciales vont
beaucoup de moments forts
les enfants partout souriant autour de
nous
[Musique]
ça